so yeah my roommate just walked out and
saw us playing drop sport game and I'm
not sure that I feel we're all coworkers
at BuzzFeed we're friends yeah that's
what it is that's what we are the start
of our friendship was through games like
we had a board game night after work do
we really want to broadcast to the
rescue oh my god we're such losers I'd
like to consider myself a board game
expert yeah if an expert means you win
all the time
every board game you play and then yes
I'm a board game expert it helps when
you cheat all the time to come down we
are here to play a mystery board game oh
man I didn't even know he had a board
game my new game is trump the game
[Music]
is this just like monopoly but everyone
goes bankrupt I'm back in you're fired I
don't know if you guys can see this the
age is adults it says it takes brains to
make millions
it takes Trump to make billions so does
that mean that Trump doesn't have brains
it also has Trump's based on all of the
bills it's terrifying because this is
what money could look like in the future
[Music]
[Music]
I mean it's not an ugly well the rule
book wow that's so complicated is this
fun back to it starts with a contract
that Donald Trump signs just to say now
you're about to play my game I invite
you to the fantasy it's even called a
trump card draw a trump card oh thank
you out coin how hold my cards are about
paying taxes I guess you can pay taxes
when you play as game but not in real
life yeah it seems like you buy these
properties and you invest money in them
it's just like a ripoff of Monopoly in a
lot of ways it's probably a shitty
crappy crappy game but it might be fun
no I feel like it's very uninspired
there's a lot of complicated games we've
tied to play and they look absolutely
absurd and yet they're okay
we still think we should give it a
chance I just don't think we've had
enough time to read the directions and
it's gonna take a long time to read the
direction
we covered it up just because we were
traveling with it alright I think we're
here we've got to leave it at this time
and dive into I got a T what does that
mean I got fired and I want to get back
in this but I can't so I think Stephen
just won another building and you have
to say it's actually kind of fun this
that bad of a game yeah
does it work for me no I did not take it
I did not take the Donald card do not
let this lie come - hello ever even
think we've been playing for almost two
hours
this is gonna be it this is gonna end
the game coming your money right now to
see who won okay
Stephen how much money do you have nine
million Stephen has nine hundred million
but eighty million dollars
[Music]
oh yeah look at in there Bella
congratulations you are the next
apprentice the game might win great
because I won it was great
kiss got lost yeah and skywalk so really
was a win-win situation it may be a
win-win for you guys it's not the best
game it's not like the first I wouldn't
be like hey guys let's play the trump
game yeah I would give it probably like
a 5 or 6 is that too high judge me
worried yeah because I won
I'll give it a 3 out of 10 the term came
shares a lot of similarities is monopoly
but it doesn't really deliver on them
and I think overall it would have been
more successful to just have a Trump
themed Monopoly game like I have planet
Earth monopoly and Nintendo monopoly
that would just offer better gameplay
and an experience I'd probably do a 4 or
5 out of 10 it's pretty much where
Trump's approval rating is that right
now
[Music]